the one thing that's probably causes
some of the most pain in chemistry and
in organic chemistry in particular is
just the notation and the the nominal HR
the naming that we use and what I want
to do here in this video and really the
next few videos is to just make sure we
have a firm grounding in the notation
and in the nomenclature or how we name
things and then everything else will
hopefully not be too difficult so just
to start off and this is really a little
bit of review of regular chemistry if I
just have a chain of carbons an organic
chemistry is dealing with chains of
carbons let me just draw let me just
draw a one carbon chain so it's really
kind of ridiculous to call it a chain
but if we have one carbon over here and
it has four valence electrons it wants
to get to eight that's the magic number
we learned in just regular chemistry for
all molecules that's the stable a
valence structure I guess you could say
so it would if it could partner to bond
with is hydrogen so as it has it has
four valence electrons and then hydrogen
has one valence electron so they can
each share an electron with each other
they can each share an electron with
each other and then they both look
pretty happy I said it's the magic
number for everybody except for hydrogen
and helium both of them are happy
because they are only trying to fit fit
they're only trying to fill their 1s
orbital so the magic number for those
two guys is two so all of the hydrogen's
now feel like they have two electrons
the carbon feels like it has eight now
there are several ways to write this you
could write it just like this and you
can see the electrons explicitly or you
can draw a little lines here so I could
also write this exact molecule which is
methane and we'll talk a little bit more
about why it's called methane later in
this video I can write this exact
structure like this a carbon bonded to
four hydrogen's bonded to four
hydrogen's and the way that I've written
these bonds right here you could imagine
that each of these bonds consists of two
electrons one from the carbon and one
from the hydrogen now let's explore
slightly larger chain so let's say I
have a two carbon chain now let me do a
three carbon chain so it already looks
like a chain so if I were to draw every
explicitly it might look like this so I
have a carbon I have a carbon it has one
two three four electrons maybe I have
another carbon here that has let me draw
it let me do the carbons in slightly
different shades of yellow I have
another carbon here that has one two
three four electrons and then let me do
the other carbon in that first yellow
and then I have another carbon so we
have three carbon chain that has one two
three four valence electrons now these
other guys are unpaired and if you don't
specify it it's normally going to be
hydrogen so let me draw some hydrogen's
over here so you're going to have a
hydrogen there a hydrogen over there a
hydrogen over here a hydrogen over here
a hydrogen over there a hydrogen over
here almost done hydrogen there and then
a hydrogen there now notice in this
molecular structure that I've drawn I
have three carbons they they were each
able to form four bonds
this guy has bonds with three hydrogen's
and another carbon this guy has a bond
with two hydrogen's and two carbons this
guy has a bond with three hydrogen's and
then this carbon right here and so this
is a completely valid molecular
structure but it was kind of a pain to
draw all of these valence electrons here
so what we typically would want to do is
at least this structure and we're going
to see later in this video there's even
simpler ways to write it so if we want
to at least do it with this kind of
these lines we can draw it like this so
you have a carbon carbon carbon and then
they are bonded to the hydrogen's so
you'll almost never see it written like
this because this is just kind of crazy
hydrogen hydrogen at least crazy to
write it takes forever and it might be
messy like it might not be clear where
these electrons belong I didn't write it
as clearly as I could so they have two
electrons there they're shared with
these two guys hopefully that was
reasonably clear but if we were to draw
it with the lines it looks just like
that so it's a little bit neater faster
to draw same exact idea here and here
and in general and we'll go in more
detail on it this three carbon chain
where everything is a single bond is
propane let me write these words down
because it's helpful to get this is
methane and you're going to see the
rhyme you're going to see the the reason
to this naming soon enough
this is methane this is propane propane
and there's an even simple simpler way
to write propane you could write it like
this you could write it like this you
could write it you could instead of
explicitly drawing these bonds you could
say that this part right here you could
write that that part right there that is
ch3 so you have a ch3 connected to a
this is a ch2 that is ch2 ch2 which is
then connected to a another ch3 and the
important thing is no matter what the
notation as long as you can figure out
the exact molecular structure as long as
you can so there's this last ch3 whether
you have this this or this
you know what the molecular structure is
you could draw any one of these given
any of the others now there's an even
simpler way to write this you could
write it just like this let me do it in
a different color you literally could
write it so we have three carbons so 1 2
3 and now this seems ridiculously simple
and you're like how can this this thing
right here give you the same information
as all of these more complicated ways to
draw it well in in chemistry and in
organic chemistry in particular any of
these this is called I call it a line
diagram or line angle diagram it's the
simplest way and it's actually probably
the most useful way to show chains of
carbons or to show organic molecules
once they we could start to get really
really complicated because then it's a
pain to draw all of the H's but when you
see something like this you assume that
the end points of any lines have a
carbon on it so if I if you see
something like that you assume that
there's a carbon at that end point a
carbon at that end point and a carbon at
that end point and then you know that
carbon makes four bonds there there are
no kind of charges here all of the comp
carbons are going to make four bonds and
each of the carbons here this carbon has
two bonds so the other two bonds are
implicitly going to be with hydrogen's
if you they don't draw you assume that
they're going to be with hydrogen's this
guy has one bond so the other three must
be with hydrogen this guy has one bond
so the other three
to be hydrogen's so just drawing that
little line angle thing right there I
actually did convey the exact same
information as this this depiction this
depiction or this depiction so you're
going to see a lot of this this really
simplifies things and sometimes you see
things that are in between you might see
someone draw it like this where they'll
write ch3 and then they'll draw it like
that so that's kind of combining this
way of writing the molecule where you
write the ch3 s for the endpoints but
then you implicitly have the ch2 on the
inside you assume that this endpoint
right here is a C and it's bonded to two
hydrogen so these are all completely
valid ways of of drawing the molecular
structures of these carbon chains or of
these organic compounds